sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luna if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show this is sponsored by blockfi if
you're entering or if you are interested
in block by um and the interest rates
that they offer then i've left the
description for you um and the link for
you in the description in the comments
section um i think right now they're
probably offering some of the most
competitive interest rates given many
companies are slashing so i definitely
recommend um checking them out so today
we are going to be talking about all the
hot stuff we're talking about censorship
we're talking about the establishment
and we're talking about the general
narrative towards crypto and joining me
for this discussion today is frank
chaparro the news director at the block
let's bring frank in hey frank how are
you
i'm good i i like your your foliage in
the background there
well this like this yeah very impressive
thank you i made it myself actually my
mom is me
good good
yeah thank you so how are you doing
i'm pretty good i'm pretty tired a lot
of um
roaming around a lot of crypto
conferences so i'm happy to be back
in my house so i can get back into my
routine
um but it's been a lot of fun i mean the
space is really
it's really energetic despite the sort
of sideways price um situation
i have never seen so much exuberance
happiness you know people
relaxing maybe after sort of you know an
arduous
you know couple of years
so it's been fun and it's nice to
kind of be a fly on the wall so to speak
and and get to
cover a lot of these different
conferences and events and i've been
doing at each one i try to do at least
one write-up to to get a
sense of exactly
what's at the center of the discourse
and conversation is so it's fun i'm
doing i'm doing pretty good
okay so for those that don't know you've
just gotten back from the bahamas where
the ftx conference took place and
something which really struck me about
that conference now obviously i wasn't
there um i haven't heard much feedback
or seen much yet
but something which really struck me was
the fact that um tony blair so for those
that don't know he was previously the
prime minister um of the labour party in
the uk um over like a decade ago i think
it was the early naughties probably um
and then there was bill clinton in the
90s
oh no we say naughties naughties is like
2000s
oh
he was so he
that's early 2000s or all of the two
naughties
interesting
yeah americans never know what i mean
when i say naughties but it's the 2001
2002 2003
yeah because it's not not
got it
not because they were a naughty period
of time that's probably a little bit of
both but um what struck me really was
the fact that bill clinton and tony
blair were speakers now i think most of
the community were quite confused by
that um so i'd like your take why do you
think that's part of it
definitely so i think part of it is
part of it has to do a little bit with
ftx and part of it has to do a little
bit with salt uh if you know the history
of salt and i got to get a bit of it
from um the man the myth the legend
himself anthony scaramucci it kind of
came out of the financial crisis a lot
of
the the sort of the the the sentiment
out of washington post financial crisis
was very anti you know flash with cash
flush with cash uh conference going
among uh the titans of finance so
basically pre-financial crisis you'd had
all these events all these like really
fancy um dinners around conferences and
whatnot and they wanted to put uh
the sentiment was you know don't do that
right a lot of people lost a lot of
money um and so the mooch kind of came
in with saul as a way to you know
revitalize that scene
um because at least from his perspective
you had a lot of hotels in places like
vegas
that weren't getting the same um
action the same um you know
traffic so to speak
and so
he started this as a way to revitalize
that
scene
but it's always been
it's always been about bringing in
outside
speakers not just from within wall
street but from the political realm the
regulatory realm
the business and technology realm
and have representatives um
speak
on topics that may be peripheral or
tangential to finance but
nonetheless relevant so i think
when you see
any sort of politician at assault event
it's it's connected to that i also think
that the when you think about the the
presence of more maybe um i mean
obviously both were
more uh relatively more liberal than
than other presidents and prime
ministers
um i think sbf and he's talked about
this is is rather keen to
present a picture of the space that is
very dynamic from a political
perspective um i think some people
outside of crypto
think of it as very monolithic in nature
right you have some of the louder voices
like a ted cruz or cynthia lumus kind of
making the most headlines about being
pro crypto and then some of the people
who make the most headlines of being
anti-crypto would be some someone like
senator elizabeth warren
of massachusetts so if you have someone
like a bill clinton and tony blair at a
crypto conference it might
give um a signal to certain people in
the political glitterati that it isn't
just some sort of
or at least not all of it right isn't
some sort of like libertarian um
anarchist community it's very dynamic
it's very multifaceted we can get these
um different types of folks to
come to our conferences and and speak
about leadership and and and
maybe how crypto can
do
good for the world um and
honestly i think i think it's it's it's
accurate of of how
the political
sort of the political breakdown is of
crypto it's not necessarily a right or
left
thing um
when you when i think about what
folks on the right like about crypto
it's kind of like you know keeping the
power of government small or minimizing
it but when i think about what the left
might like about it it's you know
banking the unbanked it's providing
better financial tools than the tools
that exist for
um you know
folks more um
you know in the lower rungs of the
economic louder ladder right um you know
the left really should should and people
have have pontificated about this um you
know elizabeth warren should really like
crypto because it's it's effectively
anti-bank and what what do
um sort of um liberal populists not like
about the banks they take advantage of
the little guy overdraft fees
etc so
i think that's how i would um break it
down a bit of sort of
a
bit of history of the historical sort of
way salt conferences are operated
and then this broader um
push among um
sam to really evangelize for a more
politically dynamic um space
and he's doing a lot of diplomatic
answer
okay that's a very diplomatic well i
think
i think some people right i mean some
people were kind of confused in as much
as
you know
is it
is it trying to make crypto seem too
um leftists i think that's that's one
argument i think another argument is
that it might add an element of balance
i understand and i think i think it is
good to have individuals there who are
from outside of the space and um
from many different um you know with
many different diverse um political
beliefs i just think that the problem i
mean i can't really speak too much to
bill clinton because like i'm not
american um but the problem that i
mainly find with tony blair is he is the
biggest advocate for um
for um what are they called uh like
they're just basically digital ids um
he's been pushing him since the iraq war
which he started so
that's my biggest issue you know he's
sort of pushing digital ids cbdc's the
whole thing um vaccine passport very
much any taking any global emergency to
track and trace people um so i feel
for me personally i felt like he's an
enemy of everything that crypto stands
for
yeah i mean i don't know much about him
myself aside from that movie the queen
oh right okay
i haven't seen one only
i think helen mirren starred in it and
she was
she plays the queen during um you know
princess diana's death and
that is probably and there's you know a
bunch there's a lot of tension between
um i forget the actor who played tony
blair but tony blair and the queen and
that's probably that is the extent of my
knowledge of his uh tenure as prime
minister so i i kind of have to
plead the fifth in that respect but i do
i mean listen i think you're gonna find
it on on both sides if you look at any
like person pounding the table or at
least becoming crypto curious they're
gonna have an aspect of what they've
said or what they believe in that does
not necessarily jive with
all of the tenants of uh
decentralization or the cryptocurrency
community
and i think that's okay right like i
think the more people who
can get in the room and and
engage with different um
community members is important but at
the same time right this wasn't
necessarily a deeply
you know crypto conference right yet a
bunch of financiers and investors and so
um that's it's a draw to have someone
who has held high office uh at one of
these events because then you can sort
of like you know um
you know rub elbows with them you know i
saw giselle that was pretty cool
um tom brady's wife oh i have no idea
yeah i only know who tom brady was in
the last only found out who was in the
last year
see that's there you go i mean that's
that's proof is in the pudding that the
crypto's empowering these folks is uh
brands
yeah but it was really it was really
interesting i mean like i have never
i mean it's just
first off the scene there like what
they're doing in the bahamas
is
is just it it
seeing it up close and in person
was
far beyond what i could have imagined
like they're
they're redefining
this small country and and the prime
minister
um obviously had a big presence at the
conference and all the local well at
least you know i didn't speak to every
single inhabitant of the island over 400
000 people
but they they're they're cool with it
they're like really like this is this is
this is really exciting you know for our
economy and
so many people are following in their
footsteps so you're gonna have about i
mean you can have dozens of companies in
the crypto space based in bahamas and it
it
mimics kind of the the the strategy of
uh francis suarez in miami
um and and other you know local leaders
who want to
attract this talent this development
and
this community which is obviously you
know affluent
but they're going to be they're going to
build an office space they broke ground
the week of um bahamas
uh crypto bahamas that can house like a
thousand people
tied in some way to sbf his charitable
philanthropic efforts the the company uh
the different companies he runs and then
some of the investments in portfolio
company
companies that that he touches all there
and they're all so many of them are
already there and
it's um
it's really it's really
oh it's almost kind of bizarre in some
in some ways
because it just happened overnight but
that's the ftx story like this like he
the whole story is an overnight story
um and you know you never know what shoe
is going to drop you nothing is ever
predictable but
it's it's pretty
it's pretty insane and they're not the
only ones right i mean i mean uh you
know i think there's there's this shift
this tide that's shifted
when you when i think about the various
places i've gone over the past few weeks
um even in paris right um you know
macron gave an interview with this um
uh a journalist friend of mine about
crypto and and they're super keen to
bring in some of the the innovation from
from london you know this is almost like
uh uh the hundred years war reimagined
but in in terms of crypto right you know
france versus the uk
and they're they're
battling it out but instead of you know
in ships they're they're doing it with
with different companies to incentivize
them to be there
and then even in dc the there's there's
been this like awakening to the
you know i used to go to dc and not that
i'm that important but i mean people
people now know like what the block is
which is pretty
interesting you know gary gensler looks
at our dashboard but i was hobnobbing
with different dc types while i was
there um i wasn't invited to the white
house correspondent dinner but maybe
next year
and these people like they're all
getting into crypto
and the policy folks it's like really
it's really interesting um how
much of a force it's become because all
of these companies now are starting to
hire policy um
and government relations folks to to
advocate on their behalf
i was talking with kristen smith at the
blockchain association the amount of
money um from from a lobbying pers or
from a um sort of individual donor
perspective one from zero to like you
know has has effectively
um you know uh now amounts to the tens
of millions
and so everywhere
it's like it's become this like force of
nature
um which is really which is really not
necessarily
captured in
the mainstream press i talk about this a
lot
crypto
more broadly in in the sort of
the zeitgeist of media is
is still defined or stuck within the
parameters of
very specific and old narratives that
have that have been um commonplace for
several years
one of which that i see time and time
again i saw it this morning in a story
in the wall street journal um
you know the
the sec is hiring uh 20
um
new uh staff or
to to sort of monitor
do something with crypto
and in the um i don't know if it was the
lead per se or in the meta um will bring
the unregulated market into the purview
of
u.s regulators and it's like how
do how does this perception and this
isn't just the journal i mean it's i see
it all the time
how is this perception that crypto is
unregulated like still
like how can you factually say that
like how can like wha how is that a fact
when
new york um department of financial
services oversees most of the crypto
exchanges here in the us coinbase has to
answer to their authority
um you know you have a firm like genesis
global which is a registered broker
dealer
sure i guess you can say none of the
exchanges are federally regulated
exchanges but that's not the same as
being unregulated right i mean these
firms uh
many of them are regulated
in some degree or another
so that's like one narrative and like
one misconception
um which is i'm gonna just jump in there
though because there are there are a lot
of narratives and we can we can go
through them um one thing i just want to
quickly refer to is when you spoke about
london and paris and even dc with more
um with more people and more countries
coming into the space i still sort of
stand by the idea that they're not
coming in
in a good way they're coming in in terms
of oh i see blockchain technology i see
it as a form of surveillance through
cbdc's um
so when we see that kind of adoption i
think that's the sort of adoption from
these
main these major places i mean you
mentioned macron macron was pushing
vaccine passports terribly i mean in his
own words he wanted to make the lives of
unvaccinated people um very very
difficult i mean he said he wanted to
piss them off and i literally quote um
so i feel like these are people who
don't have good and fair intentions when
it comes to individual liberties and
freedoms um so they're coming into this
space for sure but i think that they'll
use the technology in a bad way
i think honestly
i mean i'm sure there's there's a bit of
that like
you know certain um
certain
folks have a different view of of
surveillance
and so maybe they do see blockchain as a
way to
you know incorporate
effectively gr uh have more power over
um the folks
to whom they're they're
supposed to lead or
govern
um but i think i think it more so boils
down to jobs right like you don't want
to be the person that's chasing
jobs away and even if it's you know the
secondary or tertiary
reason for wanting to incentivize people
to operate and
do business in your country i think i
think it's a powerful one um like if you
look at the amount of employees that
many of these companies
uh employ
uh it's not in the hundreds anymore it's
not in the thousands it's in the tens of
thousands and the hundreds of thousands
um
maybe not hundreds of thousands but
certainly quite a number of people like
we've even grown at the block from
you know a year ago 30 people to over
150
and
i'm sure that we would you know explore
different um
um jurisdictions that you know where
there's there's a vibrant sort of um
and even if it's not like a financial
incentive just like
knowing that um
they they've got your back and that
they're keen to work with you and and
support you which is something i think
that mayor suarez has done a good job of
doing it that the actual like
implementation of crypto is kind of
ambiguous like yeah there's maybe a
miami coin thing or you're gonna
maybe try to do taxes it's like but
that's like that's like all right like
you know or and then to your point like
sure maybe they're like all right we
want to figure out how we can do cbdc's
but i think at the end of the day they
want to go back to their constituents
and be like hey we got this company that
wants to hire a thousand people to
either not leave or set up shop here and
then employ
people within our jurisdiction and then
that translates into downstream
economic impacts restaurants drivers and
and uh the like
so
um
i think that that's like i mean look
like
like let's be honest like why does ted
cruz like care about this space so much
because you've got exxon mobil looking
to see
uh and different gas companies looking
to get into crypto mining and he sees
all these miners coming to texas and
like
those are you know who's gonna butter
his bread
um
but but that's also good because then
you know that to to degree the the the
more that
um
the sort of power of the individuals
operating the space is recognized by
people in power the i mean it does it
has a trickle-down effect or at least
puts a stamp of legitimacy onto a lot of
the work of what um you know
we're doing here
so let's go into journalism you were um
sort of touching on that earlier i think
that there's definitely these really
bizarre narratives that keep popping up
um just a few weeks ago there was a
crazy headline which was calling bitcoin
as psychopaths saying that they are
financially illiterate um and then we
have the whole bitcoin mining is going
to destroy the environment so my
question to you is do you think that
they genuinely believe the rubbish that
they say you come from the traditional
uh journalism world so
you tell me yeah when i was at npr
affiliate
um
you know we used to talk about if it
bleeds it leads
so
that's sort of um
that's sort of uh true and i guess you
would agree in in financial journalism
um
but listen i think um
it's like you everybody operates within
the the confines of their own
view of the world right so if you kind
of think
of crypto as unregulated or
um
mainly useful for criminals and you
don't really know like you know
the back office accountant who works at
gemini or coinbase like you don't know
that it's normal people who you know
also
take their kids to you know daycare and
drive around and like you know bmws in
your nice neighborhood then you probably
don't think that they're normal people
you think they're all like shadowy like
psychopaths maybe but so i i don't think
that's the case with all um journalists
i think that's broadly you know people
who aren't in crypto would would think
about it or not think about it so let's
say you get a
let's say you get like data from
chanalysis that
shows that the amount of um illicit
activity has increased to i think i
don't remember the exact number but
let's say it was like 1.5 billion and it
increased or doubled from the year
before
you look at that and you think okay i
understand that there's this like
broader you know there's all these hacks
and crypto was used in the dark web
because those are those were the
prevailing stories so okay so it's
increasing so the story is that it's
increasing
and since that's the confined uh or the
parameters in what you're thinking it's
just building on it's just building on
the blocks that you have no pun intended
um whereas if you've been in the space
long enough and you see it has gone from
fairly
sophomoric in nature to now you know the
exchanges have done their sock ones and
suck twos and they've hired all these
people from wall street and all these
developers from google
and you see the amount of action
happening on regulated platforms and you
see
the headline number as a percentage
going down from i think it was two
percent to a half of a half of a percent
then that's
that sticks out to you so for me i'd say
okay look illicit activity is going down
which makes sense because the crypto
market's maturing but if you don't have
the that
background then
the
the sort of former story as i outlined
is easier to sort of like put together
in your mind
and i think that's the case with a lot
of different um
long i mean these are really sticky
narratives um the esg one
as another example and then more
recently the sanctions
narrative as well right like i think
it's it was such a hard thing to sort of
explain
because most people don't understand i
don't certainly i don't understand
um you know of sanctions as as well as
you know some very serious
policy people or geopolitical experts
but
a lot of people don't understand that
and they don't understand crypto so when
you kind of mix the two together and you
and there's already this underpinning
narrative that none of the crypto
exchanges like are regulated at all
it built this like powerful like really
powerful message that all crypto
exchanges are breaking sanctions
which obviously wasn't um
the case right because
sanctions were not at the time you know
you have to do no business with with
russians it's it was specific characters
specific oligarchs
um but when you think that crypto
exchanges are already unregulated you
just assume or you can assume that
then they are dealing with these types
of actors because why wouldn't they be
they're unregulated and
these wild west venues of of people who
are faceless and nameless um so i think
it's just a degree of like
unfamiliarity with with the degree to
which the space is matured and an
unfamiliarity with like who are the main
actors and
and people
um
and that translates into stories that
are somewhat out of touch i think with
where um
where the market is i think we've been
lucky enough to
have um you know we grew up
in this bear market uh the firm
and have stuck by it we have very low
retention
um and we got to see these builders kind
of come back um out of the ashes
um
and so there's a bit of like
there's a bit of um there's a bit of
context that that adds whereas at other
outfits um
you had the 2017 run-up and then as that
grew
as you saw the drawdown
um
most media outlets had their crypto
journalists sort of like leave or move
on to other beats and then now you have
a new wave of folks i would say who are
just starting to get acclimated and they
want to tell they want to you know you
want to tell tough stories you want to
make a name for yourself as a journalist
and i that's you know what's what i
tried to do and when i started at the
block we told a lot of
a lot of tough stories about you know
basis unwinding and you know the
blockchain terminal scam and bitfinex's
banking hiccups and the breakdown noble
bank i was actually or deltek or
deltek's relationship with and x
um i saw that guy in bahamas he was like
you made my life hell but it's all cool
um and so
you know you want you want to do that
you want to come out and tell really
good stories but
i think like there is this gap between
like
the maturity level um
or the sort of like reputability of most
crypto businesses
and the perception
of their reputability and and maturity
and there's mistakes i mean like
you know open c is a pretty good example
like they i mean they
i think at the uh last fall were seven
people
and now they're worth 13.3
billion dollars
in valuation
so you know when you grow that fast
you're gonna make mistakes but
and it's fine to point out those
mistakes but
i think there's a difference between
reporting
um
[Music]
being tough
and and sort of holding
power to account
and coming oh there's a difference
between that and coming
to the space from a basis
that the entire thing
is without merit
and i think that when you you come at it
from that you're you're telling pretty
boring stories if you come at it with a
with a with a degree of curiosity and a
degree of skepticism maxed with a degree
with a degree of respect
i think you're gonna get really great
stories
um and and ask really good questions
because the people are interesting like
i mean it's it's unbelievable
um some of the the founders that have
come out of the bear market and and what
they're doing
um
i mean at least from my perspective and
i i would i would beseech um
you know journalists out there in the
mainstream to look at those stories um
because it's it's pretty it's pretty
crazy
i think what's fascinating um
i'm i'm i'm fascinated by your your
sympathy for the stories and the reason
why i say that
is because i from from what i from what
i gathered from what you said it sounds
really just like um
they just don't know um my pro my
problem with that is um so go educate
yourself before you write a story i mean
i used to work for chinese global tv
network as a correspondent i was based
in paris
and god forbid i started to write a
story which i did not fully know about
oh my god i was told to call every
expert i knew about whatever i was
covering so i was covering trade wars
right i was actually covering a story
between macron and um
xi jinping um the the trade situation
and i was under strict instructions to
know the story inside out um because
you're a journalist that is that is why
journalists hold themselves to such high
degrees that's why you know journalism
used to be um you know the god's truth
it used to be the ultimate thing that
everybody sort of um really respected
and you know people really held
journalists to account now nowadays for
many different reasons journalism has
lost its um
lost its value and its credibility um so
i'm sad
that
that
if this is the case well i think it's
sad until for two reasons number one if
it's done on purpose that's sad um
number two if it's done out of just a
lack of understanding about crypto
therefore a lack of sort of education
that's even more sad um you know there's
so much information out there um with
regards to the whole esg narrative i
mean even calling bitcoin as um
illiterate and psychopaths come on
that's not laziness that's that's pure
hatred
um what do you think
um
so nick carter changed his twitter bio
to a illiterate financial psychopath and
i i didn't i didn't have the context for
that so maybe i'm not doing my job but i
thought did someone
i mean i was like no there was some
there was some article that said i mean
listen i don't know i i honestly i
wouldn't be
i'd like to see the data on on the
uh on how uh the average bitcoin person
is is more illiterate than the average
non-bitcoin person well exactly that's
what i'm saying it could be could be
true
there's no data i don't know there's a
lot of there's a lot of um there's a lot
of
questionable people everywhere but um
what i think it is is
listen like
it's a it's a it's a red-hot it it has
captured the mindshare
of the entire
world right i mean katy perry was at
this conference in the bahamas so uh and
paris hilton is is very active i heard
from someone down there that she was
doing due diligence on on on on a crypto
fund that i know so it's captured the
attention of of the mainstream jimmy
kimmel
so
news outlets are
really trying hard to put as much
resources into this as possible
and putting fairly green reporters onto
the scene
and you know i i do think you know that
they're doing
the best that they can and i think we
are too like everybody makes mistakes
and gets things wrong but
um i had an editor used to say there but
for the grace of god go i um whenever
there'd be a funny mishap that would
happen at arrival
um so do i think it's you know i don't
know i i understand i do think some of
it's like if some of it gets under my
skin too and i'll see certain things
i'm like this is just like come on just
talk to people just talk to just talk to
anybody like talk to it literally
and they'll talk to you that's the other
thing like they're so much more open
than any bank
or any sort of you know large insurance
or technology company like
and
from my perspective they're also really
open to talk about how they've messed up
and what they need to do better
um
just just do that but i you know uh my
grandmother why
yeah i think that because there's just
so much there's so many stories and
uh maybe they're under a degree of
pressure maybe these narratives that i
talked about earlier are so pervasive
that
you know at the end of the day like you
know
some of it isn't like
it's not on
it's not
it's all about perception right like
it's not inaccurate to say
that
something is x
um like it's not inaccurate to say that
the amount of like illicit transactions
is going up
even though as a percentage it's going
down it's just like the way you look at
it and it's a huge misrepresentation
it can be but i think that it's not it
it's it's a misrepresentation
when you have the context but
the thing that the thing that i would
say and maybe it's naive maybe i'm i'm a
naive person but
i would say you know don't attribute um
malice what you can to um
well the the actual quote of stupidity
but i would say um
unawareness
forgiving frank you're very forgiving
um very uh
yeah very people say i'm nice i think
i'm pretty nice
but listen it is annoying sometimes i
mean like because it's like you know
people work hard and i understand
that it's like what are we well you know
we're all trying to do something here we
all think
for me it's about the the you know it's
about um
[Music]
a lot of it has just has to do with the
people i'm like just talk to these these
folks and they all have their own
interesting stories of how they got here
and they have good intentions so when i
see like
you know certain
certain sort of like
especially like
mainstream tech reporters um just like
there's like a salt that underpins a lot
of them
and i think it's because maybe they
covered like the crisis or they covered
the tech boom
and they think
well geez like what is the to be sure
what is the catch which is part of their
job so they zero in on the what's the
catch
um i would i would offer advice as to my
advice to them would be that's fine like
you know
laser in on on
on the [ __ ] but like there's there's
a lot of interesting um
you know
stuff that's happening i mean depending
on which vertical you're coming in from
um to to report on and highlight um
but
yeah to to to my favorite my favorite
thing i've been saying recently is uh it
is it is what it is
i just love it
one of our editors hates it he says
every time you say it i just want like
oohs to fall down from the ceiling on
you
yes
you're a very passionate person so i'm
not i'm like fairly passionate but yeah
i think so yeah
yes
i'm just i'm just trying to uh
you know
all right okay find good stories yeah
but yeah it's a no but listen i
sympathize with um
it is annoying
it's definitely yeah i mean
we don't need to like we don't just go
over it but you know i'd use a different
word than annoying i'd say it's more
sinister
um that annoying but anyway but let's
keep going um
i'm interested to know what the
differences are between working
in the traditional media versus working
in crypto
um
do you feel
you can be
more political as an individual
do you feel you have more freedom to say
certain things and what you see some of
the main differences are
well i think um
i think that like one of the main
differences is we can get really
granular
on a topic i remember trying to pitch
different stories
at my previous shop and it was kind of
you kind of have to fit things into
um
like a more general audience make it
appealing to
you know many different types of people
not just like a crypto specific
audience so that's one
benefit right like you can kind of like
write about really pedantic wonky things
um and i think that's just like the dna
of our company is you know we're not
trying to
you know
try to
get as many clicks as possible like
and that's a
that's like a broader media problem so
you can kind of spend the time to do
um you know deep dives into
you know what i like is market structure
um and that's because we have a fairly
you know robust business on the research
side
uh similar to like um
you know maybe like a the relationship
between a bloomberg news and and
bloomberg
intelligence or the actual financial
services company
so that gives you a bit more bandwidth
than if you were a buzzfeed which is
solely relying on on um on clicks um and
you know it's a very it's a bad spot to
be in like i don't envy having to
um
you know
optimize for that and
we have done like you know we're we're
still in the early innings of of trying
to figure out you know
how to
you know not not optimize
from
not to be clickbaity but to even think
about like how can we get this in front
of as many people as possible and you
know we're it's a fairly robust business
um
so i guess that that kind of is two
different things there the first is we
can get really deep we don't have to
worry about like
you know
we all have our own audiences within the
firm
and sometimes we want to write for a
really niche audience and that's fine if
only like a couple hundred people read
it because they're going to get it
through the subscription product
and if we want to do something that like
like you know that's a little more like
um
you know mainstream like i did this fun
piece on
why um
larry david did the
ftx um super bowl ad i talked to the
director of it
and to the folks ftx and that was more
like that was like a very like almost
business insidery like article
um and we can do that too so i i guess
that's the main difference is we you
kind of can really laser in on a niche
audience you can cover things that are
more mainstream
um and
you have the freedom to do it and you're
and we're at least here we're not really
um
we're not handcuffed by the uh the
overwhelming
uh power of of the click
right i understand um the reason i asked
luxury because you know
you know facebook and google completely
uh with all the ad
uh
market share
well the reason i ask is because uh
a couple of weeks ago i thought was
quite interesting you tweeted we
sacrificed the edification and
development of our youngest americans
over the last few years to make our
oldest feel more safe
millions of students let me finish
millions of students are chronically
absent from school such as shame what's
going on in america right now
wow really
i liked it i liked it i really liked it
yeah i mean like listen i think that i
think that i i don't know what would
happen i don't think i tweeted stuff
like that in previous roles
i think a lot of my colleagues at the
firm probably looked at that and
thought oh geez frank you know
um but i think it's true like you talk
to regular people and they're like they
want their kids to go back to school and
it's like
you know what are we what are we doing
at what what cost everything has a
everything has a cost and i think that
sometimes we don't evaluate those those
costs properly but
yeah i think that certain sometimes um
we have a very open um
spirit at the firm um all different
walks of life all different stripes and
colors and
i we all express ourselves um good and
as long as we're respectful i mean there
are people on the team that are
you know
right on the other side and um
it's honestly really unique not to
not to you know
be um
too chilly but
i don't know if there's many places like
that where
you can have people tweet stuff like
that and then
tweet things that are antithetical to it
and then like really like get to work at
you know eight nine
and then just like really champion for
each other
um but yeah i think you know i think
like it's it's a good thing to to you
know for for some of my colleagues to
like i roll a tweet like that and then
when when they do something similar i i
roll at it as well and then maybe we
talk about it maybe we don't
get the job done
and and really respect the actual craft
of what we're doing um
so here's the thing
that was really spicy i think after that
one i probably you should do that more
often i like it i want to see more of
that kind of frank um it's good i think
that um
you see the fact that you can get on and
you know still enjoy the work that you
do together i actually think is unique
to crypto um because you ask what's
going on in america right now and i
think it's not just america it's
globally it's that people are now
identifying themselves by their
political beliefs so i actually used to
i'm a journalist by trade and i used to
journalists i don't have any political
beliefs at all okay sure for sure so i
have so i'm a journalist by trade um i
used to work as a journalist and um
there was this one
start this one thing that happened that
i'll never forget so i'll share it with
you i was working in the newsroom on a
sunday and you know on a sunday there's
only a few people in there it's very
intimate it's quite cozy
um
and it's just generally not super um
professional um i was working in london
um and i was based in kensington and
right around the corner from where our
news office was um in kensington the
sexiest actor lives right around the
corner henry cavill right he played
superman he lives right around the
corner and so the women in the office
yeah he's great so the women in the
office used to say oh you know he lives
around the corner i once bumped into him
when i was getting a coffee
um and so i was like i don't know what i
said but but i was just like oh i love
henry cavill
um and one of my colleagues turned
around to me and was just like ugh i
hate him
and i was like and she's a serious
feminist so i said oh why because of his
comments about the metoo campaign
um and she said um yeah you know he he's
horrible he's this he's that and like
this this woman went off on me in the
office um because i'm because i because
he said some comments about the me too
campaign i was like well i like him i
don't really care um and she went off on
me in the office and it was so
unprofessional so inappropriate um and
it was just truly incredible it was just
like a feminist going absolutely nuts um
because i i thought henry cavill was
quite hot um and that is and that is
like the epitome i think of the
workspace at the moment particularly in
journalism because you do have a lot of
activists um
um masquerading as journalists
um
so i think that and being able to sort
of put your opinions aside and get on
and work is unique to crypto
yeah
well i think you know going back to the
top of the conversation it like
it's not something that you know someone
like sbf is trying to meme into
existence i do think that the
the um
the makeup of the spaces is rather
wide-ranging um
and i hope that you know you know
there's some elements i mean some of it
is pretty grotesque like the things that
people say i mean but this has always
been the case with the internet but but
even in crypto like i you know
you know people do not hold back behind
their um anonymous
avatars when when sort of engaging with
people
and so it can be intimidating but at the
same time um
you know i think when you actually like
get into the dms of these these folks or
you you meet them in person
you can really
i think most are fairly reasonable
um
but at least from my experience i mean
at the block like just very open-minded
um speak your mind
and and and and without a fear of
reprisal from you it is
what it is
it's what it it is what it is it is what
it is um but it's it's
you know it's
it's you know what happens frank though
when it is what it is
people say is what it is and then they
and then they vote with their feet
so i've left london i've left that
liberal
crazy
yeah of course
because it is what it is i go where it
is
i don't like what it was i like what it
is what do you think of florida
um i love it very much i think it's
amazing um
excuse me humidity in june though have
you been there oh i've
no but it's but i can feel the humidity
it's it's pretty nuts but it is what it
is frankly so i'm not surrounded by
crazy bahamas bahamas is not
um humid at all
okay maybe i should just move there
instead that was actually the biggest
surprise the biggest takeaway from the
bahamas was that
it's it's kind of i guess like if you
look at it from like a geographical
perspective
um
kind of like in line with north carolina
or south carolina
in the states so those are very humid
places but i guess because
you have to talk to a geologist or
meteorologists i don't know who but
i assume because it's in the middle of
the ocean it's just so breezy and like
insanely pleasant
good like one of the like least humid
places i've ever been to
so this episode was sponsored by the
bahamas
no i'm just kidding i was just going no
no um definitely no it was really nice i
will do um i have another story i just
need your take on um
i want to ask you about elon musk versus
jeff bezos um and the media's reaction
to that so elon musk wants to buy
twitter and it's the end of the world
the writer is taking over not that he's
even particularly right-wing on anything
we wouldn't really know because he's not
really said his political opinions yet
um but when jeff bezos wants to buy the
washington post that is a beautiful
cultural shift that is changing america
and we should all be very interested
um
yeah
my um uber driver um
on the way was actually south african
right
um the one who dropped me off just from
the airport uh an hour and a half ago
um
and he asked me about what i thought
and
it's interesting i think that
he
like there is this desire right like you
don't
want you don't want misinformation out
there
but you kind of have to
you know
there's there's a balance between
restricting
speech
and
trying to control
misinformation
and it's very difficult
and
i spoke with this guy who was an early
advisor to facebook
um a few weeks ago right after when when
the
must thing came out and i did not think
that it would get this far
i was like you know it's funny
internally we're like should we prepare
a story about like what this means for
crypto i was like i don't think this is
gonna happen right like this isn't gonna
actually
transpire but anyway so
be that as a may i still hop down the
phone with this person
and i'm trying to pull up my notes but
we talked about like this like the the
difficulty
around like
trying to ensure that like you have
um
like a forum a place where people can
like
express themselves
and
also like clamp down on on you know
like actual
misinformation harmful information
information that can hurt people
and it's it's not easy i think that
people
certain people might view
like
everyone's knee-jerk everyone sees
things hit the wire and they
like you know even you know
with with elon like people thought oh
you know he's going to completely
open it up to the most
insane strains of society and people
it's going to be like lord of the flies
and people will be able to do whatever
they want
um i think some other people look at
them think okay like you know
finally there's gonna be
you know
there's gonna be
it's gonna be maybe
decentralized to a degree or there's
going to be
you know a clamp down on the bots and
it's it's not going to necessarily be
held to the whim
of
the public zeitgeist or the you know
ever shifting public opinion
which is good um
because you can kind of focus on what
what makes a user experience good
um
and
yeah i i don't know twitter has its
problems i think that it remains to be
seen what elon will do with it but
i certainly don't think that it's i mean
like twitter's like needs need some work
so it's a good story that's another it's
an interesting story
i think that like the
i think that the left
has somehow become a bit um
like there's like almost like a like the
word censorship like it's like
scary to a degree because because there
are i think
scary people who
you know would like to not be censored
so right how do you how do you balance
that like from their perspective and
and and that resonates with me like i
understand but
um
i think like it you know just it it it
it is what it is
no it's not just it is what it is but i
think
we'll see we'll see what he can do i i'm
very excited about like the potential
[ __ ] crypto elements that he could add
to
to the site to the experience
what kind of cryptic elements do you
think he's going to add dogecoin for
tipping
yeah i think that would be pretty cool
yeah i mean that people lose their mind
i mean they just i i honestly don't like
people really hate him
right
like i don't understand that i think
he's like really interesting
mm-hmm
i think it is going to be interesting
it is going to be interesting um i think
that it's sad and bizarre and weird that
we have to put our faith in a in a
centralized individual in order to
maintain well it's like but but it
doesn't work people have tried to do
these decentralized crypto social media
come back into the framework i can't see
you by the way sorry they just they just
suck you know that's the thing like
that's probably early frank we're still
early
yeah
it's tough it's it's
it's like you know all right someone go
build it then because oh yeah trying
i don't know
but i i agree i agree with with the with
the takeover i think that you know this
is the best that we have because the
decentralized versions don't work um so
i'm with you on that um i think that so
far it seems that he is somebody who is
going to protect freedom of speech
um and i think to be honest like he put
it really nicely he sort of said that
twitter has become this town hall of
public discussion um and it's true it's
become this global consciousness and i
think to be
removed from it is um a kind of
violation
um of i think it's i don't know i'd go
as far as to say it's like a violation
violation of of a right a violation of
freedom of speech um because i often say
that like
you can scream from your balcony right
and say i don't agree with what the
government's doing um i can scream from
my streets and
the rooftops but if nobody can hear you
and if you don't have an audience then
you don't actually have freedom of
speech um you need access to people
otherwise there is no freedom of speech
it's like if a tree falls in the woods
and nobody sees it did it even fool
right
um so i think that i and i hope that he
is going to
allow more freedom of speech
um and sort of
take us down this new path where
censorship is less
um
or even non-existent um i don't know
we'll have to see how it goes yeah i
mean
there's a lot of weird stuff on twitter
so
you know that there's a hardcore porn on
twitter did you know that
i've never seen it yeah hardcore porn
and i i know this because i don't
actually know who but somebody i
followed must have liked something and
it came up on my page yeah it's hardcore
porn on twitter um but you're not
allowed to sort of like maybe misgender
somebody by accident
um and that that basically removes you
from um the public um there's an old um
joke that ronald reagan told
when he was president
i don't know what made me think of this
but it's funny so i'm gonna share with
your audience
and it's an american and
a russian arguing about which one of
their countries is better
and the american says i can go right
into the white house
i can pound i can go right into the oval
office and pound on the president's desk
and say mr president i don't like the
way you're running your country
and the russian says
i can do that
the american says you can
because sure i can go right into the
kremlin i can run right up to the
premiere's desk i can slam in his desk
and say
mr premier i don't like the way ronald
reagan's running his country
oh man
i don't think you can do that wasn't
that what jan6 was all about he had a
lot of a lot of
good jokes
who reagan
yeah he did i liked him
yeah he had he had he used to keep him
on like postcards physical postcards
front to back index cards index cards
not postcards
um
and just tell them that was like his
thing
sign at the times
yeah why are you my great aunt um
yeah but we'll see
i mean like
i hope that i i hope that it's good
because i think twitter is
it is like where we all are you know
it's a global consciousness it just is
and if you're cut off from it then
that's a violation of freedom of speech
in my opinion
yeah but it's also a private company so
it's like
you know they they can they can deem
who
is within this forum
and not right because there is that they
have their own
freedoms
i mean
i mean we have laws about like it's like
anything just like anything else
yeah i mean we have laws about like you
know discrimination laws and like equal
pay laws and things like that you know
you could say it was a private company
they could decide how they want to pay
there's a fine line right like like if i
own if i run a bar like there's a fine
line like what i think of someone being
an [ __ ] is probably different from
what maybe a different bar manager
thinks of someone being an [ __ ]
freedom of speech
yeah it's just like compelled
i don't i mean i don't know like what
like but but if it's your
like
house or bar or whatever company you
know you you can kind of set the
parameters around i'm playing devil's
advocate no i agree with you though what
what is what what is allowed in this
forum or within this place
which is why you know we know that
freedom of speech is better and so i
hope that
you know elon musk up holds it and um
i'm still i'm just fascinated about the
way the media has covered it um
and i'm interested to watch
how the media continues to change and
shift and present things in different
ways um
whatever you should get you should get
them on the show you know
me oh thank you
yeah yeah you included it was great
chatting to you frank any time listen
long time listener first time caller
i love it that's great um
would you have any final thoughts where
can people start following you how can
people keep up with your work and what's
going on at the block
yeah i mean i have it i have a show as
well um probably not as well listened to
as um as yours but it's
the scoop podcast and i
am at the twitter for now who knows i
could get blocked by elon
let's see who knows what he's going to
do
you'll be to think at fintech frank
that i loved all the tweets about like
people going back and saying i got to
delete all my auntie elon tweets but
that's
it goes back to your point at the end of
the day and this would be my closing
thought yeah no matter where you sit
when you are entrusting any
company or or person or centralized
entity
whether you're on the right side of it
or the left side of it
you're at the whim of the discretion of
that person
and so who knows who could have came in
and bought twitter could have been
any sort of you know well
really hard to construct a deal like
that but
could have been someone who
maybe didn't agree with you
and you'd be cast out or someone who
does and then they cast out the other
side you know you really
that's what that's what you're
you know that's the sort of social
contract that exists there
um
but we yeah
we shall see it is what it is and when
you say is what it is
that leads to serious consequences
people will start voting with their feet
um and um
you know they'll always be reactions to
every every action has a consequence um
and i think we're at a pivotal moment in
time so i'm excited to see how it all
goes um frank it was so great having you
on the show today thank you so much for
coming on
thank you
thank you yeah absolute pleasure and
guys thank you so much for watching
don't forget to follow frank and if you
are watching on youtube please hit the
subscribe button and the like button so
you never miss a video we'll see you
next week